When I was in first grade,
I remember learning my colors.
We started by learning
about the primary colors:
red, yellow and blue.
Our teacher taught us how they were
the pure colors of the rainbow.
No two colors could be
combined to create them.
Our next task was to mix them
into something more complex:
green, purple and orange.
These secondary colors, especially green,
stood out to me.
I was fascinated by how two primary colors
could be mixed together
to create something nuanced
and completely unique.
When our teacher told us
that our next task was to draw
a picture of our family,
I couldn't wait.
I started by drawing my stick-figure
mom, dad and brother,
but then filled in the white space
with something else.
I’d used the washable paints I had mixed
just a few minutes ago
to create the colors of my family.
I colored my mom yellow, my dad blue
and my brother and I green.
Every time someone
asks about my background,
I'm reminded of that art class.
My mom is 100-percent
Ashkenazi Russian Jewish,
and my dad is 50-percent Korean
and 50-percent Belgian.
So what does that make me?
How should I describe myself?
Where do I fit in among the color spectrum
we were all taught in first grade?
By definition, race
is a categorization of humans
based on physical and social qualities.
The term was first used to refer
to speakers of a common language
or to denote national affiliation.
But by the 17th century,
the term referred to physical traits.
So am I white or am I Asian?
The question of race
has followed me around
for as long as I can remember.
Ever since I started
taking standardized tests
or filling out online surveys,
I’ve been asked to select my race.
And every time, I take a pause to think
about which box I should choose.
I'm white and Asian,
but I'm not allowed to click both.
So which do I pick?
Well, when I was younger,
I would always choose white.
I simply concealed
a portion of my identity
to make my life easier.
Instead of having to think
about what "other" meant on those surveys,
I would compress my identity
into one single box.
It was a quick and easy fix.
But as I got older,
I realized that "other" better reflected
my multiracial background.
But that choice of "other"
comes at a cost.
Even though I'm surrounded by loving
and understanding people,
every time I go to check that box,
I'm forced to think of myself as "other,"
or someone who doesn't exactly fit in,
like I'm some sort of anomaly
or evidence of something strange.
I don't want the world
to see me as "other,"
or the given box on those surveys.
I know there's so much more to me.
But clearly, society
doesn't see it that way.
They want a simplified view
of who each of us are.
But these days, are any of us that simple?
One of my best friends says it perfectly:
"People are like an entire rainbow,
and shouldn't be defined
by any one of their colors."
The one-box rule from test surveys
has confused multiracial people
since the beginning of the US census.
For the longest time,
you could only select one box
on being asked about your race.
The Census Bureau didn't start to allow
choosing more than one box
until the year 2000.
2000. That was only 22 years ago.
Every multiracial person
living in America before the year 2000
had to, at some point, fill out a form
stating that they identify
as one, singular race:
white, Black, Asian,
Indigenous, Pacific Islander.
For everyone in that situation,
you probably chose one of those,
reducing your racial makeup into one box.
Or you chose "other," like me,
because you're an aware
secondary color of the rainbow.
So what does "other" mean?
The definition is, literally,
someone who is different
than one already known about.
But these people who choose "other"
aren't different --
we're comparing apples to oranges.
10 percent of the American
population is multiracial,
which measures out
to about 33.8 million people.
Within that number,
there are so many combinations
of cultures and races,
yet we're all forced to fit into one box.
Not only is a multiracial
person's experience
different from those who are of one race,
but that experience also varies
from person to person.
There's a wide spectrum
forcibly contained into one small square,
an effect that minimizes
the racial experience.
Look what just happened:
the same color, but five different ways.
Categorizing all multiracial
people as "other"
is just like saying that navy
and periwinkle are the same shade of blue.
And that number, in America,
is rapidly growing each year.
In the last 10 years,
there was a 276-percent increase
of multiracial-identifying individuals.
At some point in the future,
there will be more people choosing "other"
than the handful of given boxes
on those surveys.
Though this everexpanding
rainbow is a beautiful thing,
having all of those people
have to categorize themselves
as "other" in society is not.
That's why I introduce a new idea
of racial categorization
in the form of an open-ended question.
It would recognize a spectrum
that's lacking in our world today.
One study, done by scientist
Alicia Tran and others,
showed that an open-ended question
provided an experience once deprived
when being asked about race
with only a few options.
An open-ended question
would give people an opportunity
to express pride
in their multiracial backgrounds.
As our world continues
to racially intertwine,
we will reach a point
where it will become impossible
to categorize people by a handful
of outdated and predetermined boxes.
Even now, we're seeing
a declining population
of reds, yellows and blues,
and an increasing community
of oranges, purples and greens.
As such, we can no longer expect people
to define who they are
by simply checking a primary color.
Although race is a social construct
built on a structure
of assumptions and stereotypes,
we cannot simply get rid
of race altogether.
However, the simplicity and ease
of an open-ended question
could truly lead our society
into a more inclusive and accepting world
that acknowledges the spectrum
of racial identities,
a world where all the shades of greens,
purples and oranges
are just as recognized as the reds,
yellows and blues.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)